[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade Washington Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions
for free and some say the advice is
worth what you pay for it so join us the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're glad you're
here thanks for joining us Kristen is
with us in Pittsburgh to start off this
hour hi Kristen how are you
I'm great Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well I'm calling because my husband and
I are both 55 years old we have a um a
good income primarily mine uh we make
over 300 000 a year and we have for
about the past um 10 years and
um successfully paid off our student
loans in a 10-year period over 125 000
only owe about thirty five thousand
dollars on our um four hundred thousand
dollar home mortgage wow and um have no
no revolving credit or debt we don't
drive cars that we have car payments on
we pay for those in cash
um we don't you know we don't have any
kind of debt in that way good for you
our problem is that we don't
um have a nest egg we're not saving and
so looking down the road I want to be
able to retire at some point and I'm
just trying to come up with some options
of how we should be
um taking our money and and investing it
and potentially not just paying our
children's students um
payments you know to colleges out of the
cash that we have maybe using it for
something different so you have some
cash
we did we do so I did um I get a nice
bonus every year in March how much cash
do you have
um well typically we have about 75 000 a
year and and not typically right now how
much cash do you have
oh right the second none because we just
paid two College tuitions oh she got two
in college
we have two in college one already
graduated yes okay cool
cool good for you all right and so your
cash flowing College out of your 300K
but you have no debt except 35 000 on
your mortgage
are you currently putting anything aside
fifteen percent five percent anything
into retirement
yes so I we put in 10
um in my 401k and then we also do an
additional five percent in a Roth IRA
okay so you're doing baby step four
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement right
yes how long have you been doing that
we've only been doing that since
um well the bigger chunk of it we were
doing about eight percent up until two
years ago and now for the past two years
we're up to 15 okay if you never get a
raise for 10 years you make 300 000 and
you put 15
of your income aside for retirement for
a decade you will be rich
okay you're doing everything exactly
right okay now and I mean I guess we
need to Define Rich you won't be a
billionaire but you'll be a millionaire
now but let's let's play out though what
you should be doing which is more than
that
um so okay you don't have any cash but
you have an emergency fund
yes how much is it well
um I would say that we are it's just in
our bank account with it averages
somewhere between ten and fifteen
thousand dollars okay in our bank
account I would move that to a separate
Place let's move that to like a high
yield savings account and get it out of
the checking account so that it's clear
this is money for three to six months of
emergencies maybe put a little bit more
with it yeah it sounds a little low for
three to six months okay yeah and do you
have any other non-retirement
Investments
um we have property we have two separate
properties oh and my husband is an um is
an anti-car collector and so he uses but
you don't have any you don't have any
mutual funds or stocks or anything that
are not in a retirement account
no no other savings that you're leaving
out here
no
now the other
flowing do they have debt on them
but they're not cash flowing he uses
them for his hobbyist he's a hobbyist
um for his cars so he uses them to house
those or potentially we could turn
around and sell our house yeah yeah
you're good you're full yeah I mean yeah
so you need 35 Grand to knock the house
out as soon as you knock the house out
35 Grand you got to cover tuition you
knock the 35 000 out on the house then
you're at what we call baby step seven
around here meaning there's nothing left
to do but build wealth and be
outrageously generous okay so you'll
finish up college and then you're gonna
have 300 000 plus to invest then you
would max out every 401K every Roth IRA
that you have available to you and
you're gonna even do more investing
because you're gonna have money coming
out your dead gum ears when you've got
no college students and no house payment
right
yeah we'll be excited yeah you get you
get the little goobers off the payroll
and you get the house paid off the thing
goes ding ding right
yeah so that's where you're gonna be
when's the last one graduate
so our our youngest is a freshman in
college okay so three more years okay
our daughter of a fourth year so she'll
be done next year yeah and you just
wrote tuitions yeah you just wrote yeah
so you're you know you're you're you're
getting ready to be down to one and then
then three years from now you're done
and
um your house will be paid for by then
and so you're maxing out above whatever
a little bit of tuition you got and then
when tuition's all gone three years from
today you're 58 and you're making three
350 or whatever it is at that point
and you start chunking away everything
you can in any kind of retirement
program to keep the stupid government's
hands off of your money okay yes and
then above that you start investing
further in mutual funds and in other
things that you if you buy any real
estate you pay cash for it and the next
Real Estate you buy needs to be income
producing not hobbyist
s yeah no more toys until we get the
house paid off and we got we got the
retirement underway
okay okay I got a 1960 Corvette I love
toys I'm not against toys I'm not
anti-toys I'm anti-toys when you're
house isn't paid for
okay so paying off the houses big time
easy yeah now in my in my that's why I
was searching for cash I wanted you to
pay it off today I had a feeling you had
a little bit of something under the
couch cushion somewhere and I couldn't
find it
okay I will in March oh how much is that
um probably about 80 000. oh good okay
pay a thousand Mark okay good
and then start chunking and then crank
up everything see if you'll run the math
out and good growth stock mutual funds
averaging 11 which is what the stock
markets average since it started in uh
in your 401ks in your Roth IRAs with
matches where you can you run the
numbers out on that from 55 56 years old
to 66 you're going to see an incredible
number at the end of that
okay you're fine that makes me feel
better you're fine what you do need is
you need to be very precise in what your
next steps are because otherwise you'll
buy another antique car
you are right yeah I mean we all we all
have the antique car somewhere and so
it's a metaphor for buying crap out of
order you know before we've got the
other stuff done you shouldn't be
wringing your hands about retirement and
have a barn full of cars
that's kind of that that's best that's
right that's just wrong so there you go
yeah this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
s
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America we're so
glad you are here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well one week
one week we'll be there that's right be
doing uh the student loan live stream
how we got student loan debt how we got
here how we get out that's right and you
and me and Rachel Jade being the 280
thousand dollar example of having paid
off student loans for that live stream
uh we'll be uh doing that for free for
you guys it's September the 12th at 7 pm
central time you do have to tune in live
that's it that's your shot and it is
free did we mention it's free
and it's probably worth more than that
100 it's probably worth the balance on
all your money back if you don't like it
you can't beat that
they could cut our pay in half so there
you go anyway we are yeah it's a it's
going to be a blast we're gonna there's
so much solid information out there to
give you hope and a time when it seems
overwhelming and you're standing at the
bottom of Mount Everest looking up and
you do not see Joe Biden's face so you
know that you have to climb the mountain
you know it's got to be done you know
the government is not going to rescue
you everyone has figured that out well I
see not everybody most everyone should
have figured that out by now we'll make
sure they figure if you're slow to the
party we'll get you there but we're also
going to show you not leave your
hopeless but show you what to do and
what people who have successfully done
away with their student loans make you
believe again in yourself
and in your ability to do this and give
you some tools to knock it out as fast
as possible by the way no magic answers
if I'm doing a live stream on barbecue
it's not going to involve microwaves
microwave barbecue 100 of the time sucks
and money is like barbecue it has to
cook if you think that you're going to
get out you got in a hundred thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt it
was easy to get in it's not going to be
easy to get out but we can get you out
that's right you just gotta be willing
to cook for a while that's it
so ramseysolutions.com student loans one
week from today September the 12th
Tuesday night at 7 p.m Central Time
completely free you need to sign up
though ahead of time for the live stream
and we'll send you the link and you'll
be able to turn it on pop it on your
television sit there and watch it pop it
on your computer screen even on your
little phone and you can watch it and
we'll do it just for you because hey we
you know we poke fun all the time but we
also know it's scary
and it's um overwhelming it is it's
overwhelming I hear from people all the
time on social media on Instagram and
Facebook and they don't know what to do
and I tell them I'm like look we're
doing this live stream it's practical
answers you'll be able to walk away from
it use the tools and do something that
day to better your situation so but if
you come looking for a magic wand
spoiler alert we don't have any it
doesn't exist but we will tell you what
millions of people who have been
successful in getting rid of their
student loans have done and we'll show
you exactly how to do it oh and tell
your friend who's um still living
on denial
denial River denial yeah all right
Michael is in uh Atlanta Georgia hey
Michael welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks so much for having me uh
quick quick little synopsis of our
situation so my wife and I uh I'm 29 and
she's 25. I run a small video company so
it's just myself and then we've got two
uh like 1099 contractors that work for
us
um we do about 300 and Top Line about
175 take home uh but we started
listening to the YouTube clips about six
months ago
um and then I should have started sooner
I should have listened to my wife sooner
and she was like hey we need to go full
board like no debt on anything we need
to just do the full day plan I was like
you're right let's do it so we've got no
debt on anything except a rental
property that was our first house that
we kept uh we got no debt in our
business all the cars are paid for no
credit cards anything like that way to
go my question thank you so much um so
the uh my I guess my question is so we
we bought our townhouse in 2020 right
before the World Went Crazy
um for 217 it's probably worth 340 now
um and then we moved when we found out
she was pregnant and wanted some more
space and less stairs with the dog and
all that stuff
as we have our current residents that we
owe about 3 30 on it's worth about 450.
but my question is do we should we just
go full Board sell the townhouse we've
probably got 140 000 in equity in it and
I've got about 150 in mutual funds that
I could pull out that's not retirement
uh should we just go and you could pay
off your house
that's what I'm saying but you know I
but I also say you know that that
townhouse our rental property you know
produces its rents for 17.50 we could
probably get a little more for it we're
in North Atlanta in a great area so you
know do we should we pay the townhouse
off or should we just go full board and
get the house knocked out before I'm
even 30.
okay
well one way I make some of these
decisions and if you've been binging
YouTube you've probably heard this
before as I reverse engineer it
sure let's pretend you did not have
money in a mutual fund and you did not
have a rental property and you were
sitting in a paid for 450 000 house
and you woke up this morning and said
I'm gonna go borrow 330 000 on my home
in order to buy a rental property and
put 150 000 in mutual funds
would you do that
I don't know that I would
that what that does is is it makes you
also think with your heart where you
measure risk
because when that when you say that you
go women I got paid for home and for
just a moment there you were sitting in
the you know out on the patio or the
cool cup with a great cup of coffee and
on that paid for house and for just a
moment it was paid for and then I took
it away from you your stomach jumped up
into your throat a little bit even
though it's not really paid for it was
just a discussion but it still causes a
physical reaction doesn't it
yes absolutely yeah that's real once we
had our daughter that's right I I was
much more risk-averse before our
daughter came here I was like oh no
we'll go for it we'll do all these
different things I wanna I'll do ten
rentals like we're just gonna get after
it yeah and now I'm like I don't know
how it feels outside now you're the
antithesis of tick tock right so
um you know you grew your brain in
that's good having kids does that having
kids will do that for you
I'm saying all of that to say I
personally would sell it and pay it off
and be debt free because I am I'm the
end of the story okay you're you're 31
Oh no you're not even 30. you were doing
this before you're 30 right
yes sir I'm 29. yeah I'm 63. so I did it
when I was your age
and now I've got a whole bunch of real
estate and it's all paid for I paid cash
for it as I bought it and it really does
cash flow when you don't have payments
on dude
yeah like I found it with a gun yeah
yeah I'm just saying so yeah I mean so
the end of the story is it's not that
you will be without real estate as an
investment the end of the story is is
you've learned that real estate's a
great investment you've also learned
debt free is cool and the shortest path
to wealth and so I predict that when
you're 40 you'll own several pieces of
real estate that you paid cash for that
make you a lot of money
love it yeah there it is I love that I
love that reverse engineer because it
helps you see what you truly value
in a moment yeah that's a that's a good
way of saying it you know and you can do
that folks with anything I mean if
you've got a boat sitting in the
driveway you can go uh if I had that if
I had that fourteen thousand dollars in
or forty thousand dollars or whatever
that boat is right in a pile in the
middle of the table would I go buy a
boat you go yeah use a stinking thing
every weekend yes I'd go buy that boat
and you keep the boat right that's right
you keep the boat I got two boats and
two jet skis and I was down there this
weekend at the lake house and um you
know I I'm not selling those no not
happening uh they're not for sale yeah
and you know I got two mastercrafts the
best ski boat in the world and I got the
opportunity to buy one finally when I
got some stinking money but yeah um you
know what was that so so no I'm not
selling the boat but you you can reverse
engineer and decide to keep it yeah
that's right that's a good mental
exercise to go through though yeah with
almost anything so yeah very good
Michael I would do that but only on the
caveat that you play all the way through
and become rich and pay cash for your
real estate
so I want you to join the baby steps
millionaires league and you're not far
away and you're not even 30.
and then you know then you start saving
up and paying cash for Stuff
the weird thing is it's a reverse debt
snowball in
like when you buy your first rental
property with nobody with no debt you
make a lot of money on every month
because you know what I mean there's no
ex you got expenses
and so you got money in the account
every stinking month stacking and then
you use that money pretty quick buy
another one now you got two of them
stacking that's real well I like and you
got four of them stacking and I just buy
real estate from my real estate yeah
that's I don't even touch my regular
income to buy real estate now it's just
an income snowball
ooh I like that I like that too this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions by the way you
ought to come by and visit us we've
usually got 50 to 200 folks sitting and
watching us do the show we do it from
one to four central time every weekday
afternoon and uh we'd love to have you
come out and hang out with us the lobby
is of course free there's all kinds of
Ramsay things to do around here
including free coffee and free homemade
chocolate chip cookies and you get to
watch from the debt free stage some debt
free screams Isaiah is here to do just
that hey Isaiah how are you hey how's it
going better than I deserve where do you
live sir I live in Tampa Florida awesome
very cool welcome to Nashville and how
much debt have you paid off sir 176
thousand dollars yeah yeah how long did
this take it took me six years good for
you and your range of income during that
time I began at 41 000 and I ended up at
around 95 000. wow good for you wow what
do you do for a living I'm an I.T guy
and for my side gig I'm on the radio I
knew it
have a great radio voice that's
now burst oh it's all good
you do so what are you doing radio uh
producing shows from fishing shows
Sports shows any type of thing they want
me I'm here let's go let's have some fun
and get to do some Voice work in the
middle of it I do yes very good good for
you very fun what kind of debt was the
176. it was just a mortgage you paid off
your house yep that was it look at it
game oh man way to go it wasn't anything
related to you know mortgages credit
card debt now I already had that done
and gone out of the door yeah just a
mortgage just a mortgage six years ago
you get on this journey making forty one
thousand and you end up paying off your
home and everything making 95 in the end
of the story how old are you I am 34.
what's the house what's the house worth
uh now it's worth almost four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars and how much
is in your retirement accounts uh I wish
it was a little bit more it's around 150
000. good for you they're going you're
killing it wow you're 600 already in
your 600 000 net worth and you you're
only 30 man that's just great I gotta
keep going yeah you're on your way
you'll be baby step millionaire in no
time excellent excellent okay so what
happened six years ago that put you on
this Ramsay Journey so what happened was
that I was getting my mortgages and I
was just paying the minimum and I was
looking at the interest and it was just
a couple of pennies every time that was
going less and I'm like just a couple of
pennies that's it so I was like you know
what let me do something let me research
something and I was recently single too
at the time and I was going on Facebook
and I was like dating group I was
scrolling around and I found something
for Dave Ramsey dating group I was like
we saved Ramsey I mean
so I I began to do some research and I
was like oh a finance crew let me
actually jump in a little bit let me
talk to these cool cats they were
talking about baby steps and I was like
what is baby steps so I began to do more
research I was like oh okay so right now
I'm on bs6 how can I do bs7 so I was
thinking of going to gazelle mode which
I Rich yeah and then I was like okay
let's go gazelle let's do what we need
to do to get that to be zero there you
go so very cool yeah it was fun it was
exciting it really was so who was on
your side during all this you you decide
that you're going like animal mode going
gazelle mode on this mortgage were there
people around you who are like dude
you're 34 like you can just you've got
time or was there somebody who was like
come on dude just me you you need to
have ambition you need to have the
passion it's just because what I saw
with my with my family I saw my mom she
was one of those 1980s you know oh
credit card let me slap it and forget it
type of thing and then it took around 25
years to pay that off so I was like you
know what I don't want to be like that
let me do something different and you
just have to be self-motivated because
being that free is great yeah
so the the odd pop-up site that we have
by the way disclaimer we have nothing to
do with any dating sites nothing nothing
yeah full disclaimer here and yes it's
been proposed as many times as a bean
beans and rice cookbook so don't send me
the proposal okay we're not doing it why
not oh man I'm just glad I'm glad you
wandered in the back door man it's just
amazing man it's very cool the dating
group had some cool cats in it and you
know I I had a lot of fun and we all
helped each other out into resolving to
become everyone being debt-free I love
it really nice very good wow good for
you man well done how's it feel to not
have a house payment at 34 years old I I
don't I don't know what to do with my
money exactly let's reinvest it let's
let's put it up in my 401k let's Max it
out that's awesome good for you that's
really cool are you are you doing
anything to celebrate are you going
anywhere what's the big trip what's
actually I had a uh big party a few
weeks ago actually over at my house I
invited my friends it was like a double
party because not only did I become debt
free but I also got uh I finished off in
my second bachelor's degree
with my job they do free education
always max out those benefits so that's
what I did and got myself a second
bachelor's and I'm going for my Master's
and I'm looking for my doctorates let's
go wow why not game on yeah yeah I'm
like you don't have to pay let's go this
is very there's nothing wrong with this
no I'm not done sir thank you done well
done okay so when the guys at the party
they said okay you're 34 years old you
have paid for 450 000 house this is
weird
how did you do that what do you tell
them the key is to getting out of debt
the key is be self-motivated is to have
passion within yourself because if you
don't have that passion you're not going
to do it and don't listen to most of
that media saying that debt's cool
that's not cool you know you got to pay
off the debt you got to get yourself
debt free and it's like change it's like
it's like being uncuffed from being in
prison or something you know you're free
you can do whatever you want and it's
and it's fun and it's a cool Journey
from going from different baby steps and
whatnot and I try to encourage my
friends to do the same thing and live
that Ramsay lifestyle wow and someone
will do it some of them won't that'll be
perfect well very good man
congratulations proud of you thank you
we're excited for you well done and
appreciate you taking the trip here to
Nashville to do your debt free scream
we've got the live and give box for you
for you to have the baby steps
millionaires book which is definitely
the journey that you're on you won't be
there forever it won't be long for until
you're there and Total Money Makeover
book to give to somebody and get them
started and even Financial Peace
University members ship all of that just
to say thanks for coming up here and you
can live some of it you can give some of
it so it's perfect sounds great very
cool very cool who did you bring along
to cheer you on here uh my friend
Jocelyn she too is on the Dave Ramsey
Journey baby steps right now so she
wants to see what the good life is like
all right here we go all right find out
what it's like to be truly weird well
done Isaiah you've joined the club my
man I'm proud of you all right Isaiah
from Tampa Florida 176 thousand dollars
paid off in six years making 41 to 95
000. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one on debt free
oh
that is how it's done yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes man his enthusiasm
was contagious infectious you know the
first time I took a call or somebody on
the debt free stage that had paid off
their home I was aghast
and then the first time
I had somebody that was like 40 years
old
pay off their home I was aghast and now
it seems like every week we've got a
30-something in here with their homes
paid off I know and are almost
millionaires already uh it's like
happening earlier and earlier and
earlier the stronger generation is
catching on faster than the Boomers did
that's true yes they are I'm
yes aghast is the word yeah it just it I
mean it's wow wonderful not a payment in
the world and he's not even 35 years old
yeah and light is a fact light is a
feather not touching the ground when he
walks I mean that's this is how it works
you know it's it because you don't have
to carry all those chains around and uh
you know it changes how you work it
changes where you work it changes the
quality of your relationships your
ability to set boundaries in toxic areas
of your life when you have no money
problems
is pretty powerful yeah and uh he he
didn't have that in his story that we
know of anyway but just to let you know
if you don't have any payments and the
ball starts yelling you can just start
walking off yeah I'm leaving where are
you going I don't have any payments
I'm not putting up with this crap next I
mean it changes everything boys and
girls changes how you walk
and uh because you're not you don't walk
like a slave anymore you walk like a
free person
changes
it's worth it it's hard
but it changes everything this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45 off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May apply
[Music]
thank you
great washout Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America
Aston is with us in Ashton is with us
Aston I'm sorry is with us in Akron Ohio
hi Ashton how are you
hello I'm good how are you thank you so
much for having me sure how can we help
so I since I have met you through the
interwebs I have referred to you as my
financial father prior to discovering
all the Ramsey products I didn't know
anything about how to handle money that
was never discussed growing up and
neither did my husband
um but with all the time we had on our
hands staying home at the beginning of
the covid crisis
um we found you again and we signed up
for Financial Peace University we
dedicated every Sunday to go join the
class online we went through it uh that
was February 2020 since then we've paid
off 160 000. why did it go yes so my
next call will be a debt free debt free
scream and hopefully we can do it in
person but
um that's uh hopefully soon but we have
our house left of course and about 45
000 in debt uh left to pay off aside
from the mortgage and really I'm looking
for advice or some kind of push on how
to gain some traction we kind of feel
like we're stuck I don't know if it's
been a change in
just all the changes with the world
today and the prices of things we also
have my mom living with us since March
so that's changed some things
financially and covering her expenses
um but I feel like this last 45
000 is it just feels like forever it's
not like it's not going anywhere is it
because your margin has dramatically
decreased or is it just you're getting
tired of chucking the money towards the
debts every month
I don't think we're getting tired I I
know that we're still pretty excited
because I mean we we do still have our
meetings my husband and I we do them
every other week uh where we're sitting
down and looking at our budget and our
spreadsheet of all things and
um we see how it's working it's just for
some reason this 45 and then how our
budget has added to
change so you don't have as much money
going towards it
oh no we do have money going towards it
you have as much as you used to
oh yeah yeah we do okay all right let's
stop a second what's your household in
okay
um bring home is 143.6 okay and how much
are you how quick do you think you're
gonna have the 45 done
what's your project I'm hoping to have
it no no you got numbers it's not hope
what are the numbers what 16 months 16
months
one six
for 45 000 making 145 000. so you can't
live on a hundred
what's that you can't live on 100 for
the next year
uh we can we're we're also paying
um well like we have my mom living with
us too so all of her how old is your mom
you know just 66.
okay you started you're muffled like you
cover your phone or something
um all right 66 66 okay yeah and why why
is she living with you
uh she had to move out from her home due
to some domestic violence
okay so there's a divorce in process
uh no no divorce involved no she wasn't
married at the time now so she didn't
own the home
it wasn't her home
no she was renting is she able to work
at all
she does work some yes does she take
Social Security
not yet no because she contribute to
your household at all
she does when she can she has a lot of
medical bills that were owned from from
that uh attack I guess if you want to
call it
um so she's covering those bills at the
time she didn't have insurance
because she got you know hit with all
the bills so trying to help her where we
can
um
so like the grocery bills all that has
adjusted
um how many kids do you have
we have three kids
okay so mom's in the house
correct me if I'm wrong mom's in the
house so now you're buying a little bit
of extra food there's maybe a little
increase in water
electricity that sort of thing
that's not that's not changing yeah that
doesn't feel like the reason that this
has slowed down my question to you I
asked it a couple of times and I felt
like you're kind of going back and forth
I think that you're just
um one of two things is happening either
you're not putting as much money to the
debt and therefore it's not moving
which it sounded like you said initially
but then you said no we're putting just
as much on it so no you better be true
you paid off 160 000 right
yes yes in what period of time three
years uh from February 2020 to well
August
so almost three years yeah almost yeah I
think
based on what you're telling us it's 55
000 a year
yes
yes okay that's not 45 000 over 16
months
so your energy has slowed down you're
not putting as much towards the dead as
you were yeah that's what we were saying
you should be done with this in like 12
8 to 12 months somewhere in there if you
turn it back up I think um I don't know
I'll give you a guess you the way you
mentioned Mom and then you tell us what
has happened with your mom the trauma
she's been through and how um
the emotions around some dirt bag
hitting your mother to the point that
she needs medical attention are very
strong
if you're a redneck it means you want to
kill somebody okay like him okay not
saying you should I just said it makes
you want to because that's actually what
he deserves okay so uh but the uh so the
emotions around that so not only did mom
come in and is eating a little bit of
food what Mom did come in and do was use
up a whole lot of your emotional
bandwidth right now yeah
yes I agree I agree which is okay
because you're supposed to take care of
her because she got the crud beat out of
her that's horrible right I mean I'm so
glad you're there for her but I think
you're you know you guys had a singular
purpose in life coming out of the fauci
quarantine
your singular purpose in life was get
out of debt
wasn't it
yeah and now you've got like two or
three purposes
and so it's it's diluting some of your
emotional focus and energy uh at least
one of the purposes is valid but just
recognizing that it's there helps you
deal with it and that is I'm probably
slowing down just because I'm you know
mom's situation is taking up some part
of my emotional bandwidth
I think she's hitting you all harder
there than she is in the pocketbook
I would probably agree with you yeah and
again I I want to validate that I think
that's probably the right thing to do
she needs you to be there
she needs to remember she's not a victim
that or she is a victim but she's not a
worthy of what happened to her because
that's what goes the shame that goes
with domestic violence so helping her
turn the corner on this and getting her
to where she can contribute to your
household financially would be good for
her dignity in this as well so that'd be
okay if she started either getting a job
or collecting Social Security I don't
care which and dumping that in the
middle of Euros table to help cover the
the you know food and housing right now
that's good and and then we also need to
work out a long-term plan
which is not her living here for 25
years
um until she's 94. we're not doing that
so we gotta we need a better plan than
that but short term you've been a safety
net and you should yeah I think they're
I think you're right Dave I think you
hit on something with the emotional part
because I think that's what people tend
to do when something emotional happens
every it's like you go out to dinner
more you're tired you don't cook it as
much at home you she doesn't probably
doesn't want to say no to much of what
her mom is requesting like there's all
of these things that make you feel like
how can I help how can I just decompress
from this moment and unfortunately
sometimes that includes spending dollars
and I think that's what's happened here
you relax and as soon as you relax money
flows to stupid sure does and I'm not
saying you're doing a bunch of stupid at
all I I don't think you are but there's
singular focus is what got you 160 done
in two and a half years and singular
more singular Focus to the extent you
can and still take care of your mom is
what will get you moving again kiddo
you're doing better than it feels like
you're doing I think I think so too and
I think you're an amazing daughter well
done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money Mike is with us in
Wilmington North Carolina hey Mike
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um I have
um my wife and I have been talking we're
considering selling our home
um of course the prices on on the houses
should just skyrocketed and uh so we
could put a lot of money in our pocket
so right now we owe approximately
243 000 uh that's a mortgage and a HELOC
um and our total date is two little over
in uh credit card
um we got five thousand a little over
five thousand five thousand one hundred
left on a car
and a personal loan from a family member
from a few years back of like 26.5
uh so we're paying on all of that every
month so total debt a little over 299
243 of it is the house
um we talked about possibly filling the
house
because after selling the house
um paying the fees and closing and
mortgage payoff HELOC and everything
uh and then paying off all of our debt
uh could be in completely debt free we
would have approximately two hundred and
seven thousand dollars in cash
uh we could set aside you know thirty
thousand dollars for emergency fund for
six months
and still have a a pretty good lump sum
that we could put away somewhere for a
year until we decide what we want to do
and and find another house for a year or
two how much do you make what's your
income
uh my income ain't um
annually I'll say monthly is 11 500 but
that's not every month my I work for a
utility company and so spring and fall I
make a little more uh other times it's
straight 40 hours a week yeah
the average is out excuse me does your
wife work outside the home
she does not okay so your household
income's around 130 right
the 130 135. you got about fifty
thousand dollars of non-mortgage debt do
you not like your house
uh I do like the house uh it's in a nice
location and convenient to everything
does your wife like we got the house had
a good deal yeah she likes it we we
picked it up the way we wanted it
because it needed a total Remodel and
I have I have a theory
I have a theory can I tell you my theory
yes ma'am I think that you're kind of um
trying to get around
what it might take to pay off fifty
seven thousand dollars of debt
and I think in your mind the easiest
route is because in real estate markets
up we can sell our house we can get this
money we can knock all these things out
quickly
but I'm not sure
that that's going to be the solution to
your problem
we can knock out the HELOC we can lock
out knock out this personal loan knock
out this car save up our money it's kind
of like a quick fix but I'm looking at
your income and I'm like wow if you love
the house you fixed it up the way that
you want why not just walk through the
process of budgeting
cutting down your lifestyle to nothing
sacrificing and just paying off this
fifty seven thousand dollars of debt
with intensity then you'll walk through
the process of saving up three to six
months of expenses make 135 put 30 a
year on it for two years you're done
you're done
and you get to keep the house that
you've made exactly the way you want it
and here's the side benefit of that
you will have fixed the guy
and the gal
that caused this mess in the first place
because they will have learned to quit
using the stupid butt credit cards are
borrowing to buy a car and for God's
sakes won't be borrowing from family
ever again
because I mean if you'd learn to live on
less than you make dramatically to pay
off debt it changes the person in your
mirror
which which is your long-term
sustainable fix
the house thing doesn't change the
person in your mirror
and you if you don't change your habits
even after selling the house you'll be
back in debt in five years
that make sense to you
yeah it does there were there was some
little background behind that my wife
and I actually divorced
a little over a year ago we were
separated three and a half years ago we
divorced a little over a year ago
we both came to the realization and and
and that we're better together I went to
a Christmas play last year and it said
there's nothing too broken or too far
gone that God can't fix amen and and we
God healed your marriage and you're back
together we got back together
very cool yes that is very cool that is
awesome yes how does that that's a
beautiful Story how does that uh
keep you it would seem to me like that
and equips you
to do hard things together
it does absolutely yeah instead of yeah
so let me ask you this in that context
maybe we keep trying to read your mind
that's not fair but
um in that context are you just trying
to do something nice for her get rid of
this stress
without her having to feel it the stress
is more the stress is more of me because
I am the one that works outside the home
and I see yeah but you you want to clean
this mess up without causing this lady
that God gave back to you
any inconvenience
either that or this debt represents I
want to be able to have this money set
aside to basically so we can start
leaving them I'll be 58 years old and
and um I want you to take two years in
order 60 your debt free except your
house that's what I would tell you yeah
I mean and we already but when we
divorce we never split up anything so
everything is stealing both of our names
I still have the IRA with three rental
properties in it that's paying income
into the IRA hey Mike worth over uh like
1.2 million
even even more reason
to pay this off in less than two years
even more reason
I'll go ahead and drop a three rental
property uh bomb on me at the end of the
call and I don't know what to do with
that okay so except it's in an IRA so
you can't touch it so we'll just keep
moving but uh
yeah if I was in your shoes I would grab
her by the hand and say honey we just
finished one hard thing let's do one
more hard thing and let's roll up our
sleeves and live on nothing for the next
18 to 24 months and be a hundred percent
debt free except our house get rid of
the family loan praise God thank you
Jesus whoa has anybody ever said family
loan and it made you feel all warm and
fuzzy not gives you the heebie-jeebies
yeah
wow it's not good just lost two more
hairs oh my gosh gotta go through the
process Steve that's what I would do man
and hang on we'll sign you guys up for
Financial Peace University we'll be uh
part of the next chapter of your
marriage growing and healing and show
you guys how to work this stuff together
uh it will work and I I personally if
unless you hate the house I would
definitely not sell it I would fix the
guy in my mirror and get this
overspending down and cause it to be
under spending and use it to get out of
debt
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
well a week from Friday and Saturday
we'll be in Chicago doing a smart
conference if you want to be smarter
we'd love to have you we'll actually be
up north of Chicago but Willow Creek
Church that's the venue that we're using
they're letting us come there and do our
smart conference on Friday night and all
day Saturday we'd love to have you if
you're in the Chicagoland area Jade will
be there speaking George Campbell Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney Ken Coleman we're
going to be talking about every area of
your life it is a wonderfully
entertaining Friday night and all day
Saturday you will leave inspired and
informed and smarter that's right what
are you going to be talking on this year
I'm going to be talking about reclaiming
your freedom from debt there you go okay
which is what you did that's right
exactly smart conference Chicago go to
ramseysolutions.com events you can still
get a ticket I think
so check it out I think you can still
get in we'd love to have you make a plan
Jill is with us in Dallas Texas hi Jill
welcome to the Ramsay show
oh hi guys it's a real honor to talk to
you um I need your math skills Dave I
have a 17 sorry 18 year old
granddaughter who's in her last year of
high school and wants to go to college
and I just found out that her father is
refusing to pay any college fees for her
and I'm devastated so I want to set up
an account possibly in a mutual fund uh
for her I don't have a lot of time I
have about a year to graduate next
spring and then go to college a year so
and I was wondering what kind of mutual
fund I could put it into to gain the
most
um
whatever not not enough to fix this
no how much would I have to invest I
have some money
17 year old
granddaughter
yes but I raised her
you raised her
yes from the time her parents weren't
married and
um my husband and I did a lot of
babysitting and and practically raised
her and helped him out tremendously and
if I don't regret helping her out I love
her
I wasn't questioning that I was just
trying to get understand what's going on
here and so uh you've you've been in the
family for 20 years
oh more than that yeah but since she was
born right uh-huh okay
um so
the stepson doesn't want to help or just
can't help her dad
he's he's got a lot of problems he's a
narcissist my husband passed away three
years ago that was his father and left
him some money and he's blown off he's
blown through it you have no money left
and he's had another child and he's not
married so trying to get help from him
is not going to probably work okay
so this is not a complete family unit
that you're interfering in more like a
splintered family unit and you've been
the one holding it together you and your
husband before he passed
my granddaughter
in touch with her she and I are fine how
much can you devote to her College
well I have quite a bit of money
and I'm hesitant what's quite a bit
I have about a million one okay that's
good well done yeah so how much do you
want to devote to her College
well that's what I kind of needed to
help you help me with I um let's pretend
that we didn't try to invest our way out
of this in one year which is called
called desperation and sets you up for a
get rich quick or get get scammed or
something we're not going to do that
let's just try to get a plan together
and pay for this kid's College all right
okay so the average in-state tuition
what state does the Child live in
she lives in California she is talking
about going out of state but I'm not
sure where yet she doesn't know yet
average grade yeah at the very least we
can start can she move to you can she
move in with you
well I'm going to be there in a couple
of weeks and talk to her yes and I was
going to ask her if she wanted to
entertain that yeah I want her to have
Texas
uh residence and you need to find out
what that means for the University of
Texas at Dallas
okay because not it's not a bad school
at all and Texas yeah and
um not Austin I'm talking Dallas
I can live with you and go there and get
a great education
yeah that was in the back of my mind and
like I said I'm going to talk to her and
her mama in a couple of weeks okay so
here's the here's the thing
school choice is 90 percent of the
problem with student loan debt
yes people pay stupid prices to go to
stupid schools and study stupid things
and they get stupid
okay so let's don't be stupid about
education this is a kid from a
splintered situation her step
grandmother for God's sakes her fairy
godmother is stepping in to fix this
guess what you're going to use that
muscle to force her to make good choices
for her own good good choices is
reasonable College tuition out of state
tuition by definition is not reasonable
in this situation
okay you are paying for nothing except
you cross the state line it is
absolutely zero value
zero one of my kids applied we live in
Tennessee when they were in college age
applied for and was accepted to the
University of Mississippi which is a
wonderful little SEC school no problem
with it at all only it's three times the
price of the University of Tennessee
because it's across a state line
right so instead of today's world
instead of uh 25
000 you pay 8 000 to go in state to
basically the same school
just a different color on the football
jersey okay well and some play better
football than others but anyway but
aside from that right so you know the
number of people that have applied at
Ramsey we have 1100 folks working here
that we did not hire because they went
to the University of Texas at Dallas
versus the University of uh Timbuktu
across the state line is precisely zero
as a matter of fact we count it towards
your wisdom and count it towards a badge
of honor to get hired if you used some
dadgum sense while getting your degree
does that make sense right so this is
what you put your little arm around her
Little Neck and explain life to her
Granny's gonna pay for this but you're
gonna do it Granny's way
[Music]
and then you can get through this for
she can go to Community College for two
years if she wants to probably pay
nothing get her get her requirements out
of the way or core stuff out of the way
and you can get through this for under
50 Grand
well that would be great no it's not
great it's factual
yeah but for me it would be okay yeah
yeah you can handle 50 grand out of 1.1
and you would right you do that in Army
but am I going to spend 150k for her to
get basically the same education through
a series of stupid butt choices at other
places no no she does not need a lazy
river
some of these stupid but schools have a
lazy river you can ride through in an
inner tube yeah this is how stupid but
this stuff has gotten
she just is uneducated regarding this
and I'm going to have to educate her
well these are the let me tell you in
our stuff that we've studied and Jade
we've talked about this a lot
um Anthony O'Neill that was a Ramsay
personality African-American guy for a
long time we kept he kept saying it was
African-Americans that were running up
uh student loan debt uh uniquely in
ridiculous degrees and I said no that's
not it I don't buy that and so we got to
dig into it he and I were digging into
the research and what we found was just
exactly what you described it has
nothing to do with skin color it has to
do with first generation to go to
college
whether you're you know whether you're a
hillbilly like me or African-American
first generation to go to college
doesn't have college educated parents to
guide them through the stupidity of
higher education
that's true and so they end up spending
250 000 getting a degree a master's
degree in sociology so they can work at
the state making 38 000 as a caseworker
which is dumber than crap
I've listened to you guys a long time
talking about this and it really upset
me when I first heard that she was going
to take out student debts no she's not
she's got a grandmother's not going to
let her yeah I'll take care of you but
you're going to do it my way no debt
we're going to choose a school that is
reputable and a good solid education
okay great advice great advice thank you
so much thank you you can do this you're
a good lady I will yeah I will take
control for her sake take control of it
don't don't be acquiescing to 17 year
olds wishes
that you're not you know she don't even
though I'm your Fairy Godmother you get
no wishes
this oh that's a line
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Tim and
Karen are with us hey guys how are you
good good we're great welcome where do
you live
we live in Detroit Michigan ah cool
welcome to Nashville good to have you
guys and all the way here to do a debt
free scream how much have you paid off
eighty thousand all right how long did
that take about five years good for you
and your range of income during that
time I think we were at 36 000 and then
now we're at 88 000. good for you well
done what do you all do for a living
um I'm an apprentice for for uh
uh foreign for an electrical company and
um I'm in finance okay great great very
cool what kind of debt was the 80 000 uh
school debt
um a lot of it and then uh credit cards
and car payments very good good for you
guys way to go man
proud of y'all very well done thank you
thank you all right so you paid off
everything but the house
you're 100 debt free right now yes way
to go very good five years starting out
making 36 000 bucks how long y'all been
married 25 years uh this year so that
that's kind of why we came to Nashville
to see you but also celebrate 25 years
of marriage amen amen so at 20-year Mark
you're in debt 80 grand mm-hmm
this sucks yeah we did stupid and you're
going uh I don't like this so whose idea
was it to make this change and how did
you guys do this and how did you connect
to Ramsey uh well I'll let my wife
explain that well
uh we first heard about Dave Ramsey
um from your parents about 20
three years ago from my family but we
thought you were a pyramid scheme ah
okay
yeah
we no we only sell snake oil
and then
um fast forward to about seven I believe
seven years ago I was talking to a
friend and um uh shout out to Helen and
Charlie
um we were talking and she was talking
about she read your book and
um she was talking about how they were
going to get out of debt and they were
going to become Millionaires and I was
like what you joined the pyramids world
are you talking about I really I thought
it was just I thought it was a scam yeah
and so uh she said those of us in
finance we have a high degree of
spiritual cynicism which is a good thing
I agree with you I would have thought we
were a scam too yeah so
um so she said you got to read the book
and so we actually watched the DVDs um
read the book and we drank the Kool-Aid
and um and we've been crazy ever since
all right I love that you watch DVDs
that's great yeah those were five years
ago
yeah good on VHS I guess
yeah
come on Jade I just haven't heard
it hurts great
what happened with your income it went
from 36 000 to 88 000 what happened
there so I was a stay-at-home mom for uh
17 years we have four adult children now
but of course back then
um
uh seven years ago or so they were they
were smaller
um younger and um
uh one of our sons is Special Needs um
he's high functioning and he's doing
great now but at the time he couldn't be
home he couldn't be alone and so we
decided that I wanted to go back to work
um but we had a unique situation because
he can't be home alone he can go to
school but somebody has to be home when
he's home and with school schedules and
working eight to five we just we were
looking for an option
um and so I went back to school got my
degree I went back to school or went
back to work full time by then he had
matured enough that he could be home
alone
um so he's he's doing great that's
awesome so I went back to work and um
and did lots of side gigs
you guys over doubled your income
between these yeah we sold everything
yeah I told the kids if they Stood Still
long enough I would sell them there you
go I like it I like it Wow way to go you
guys side gigging is a side gang is a
real it
people don't realize you talk about it
but there are so many side gigs out
there oh yeah
um what was the best one that paid the
best for you
you need yard sale Rob well we did
oh
I used to um when I was in school I was
I was wanting to be out of debt so bad
but I felt so limited because I I didn't
feel like I had a marketable degree we
we both graduated from college 25 years
ago but with degrees that were not
marketable and so that's why we had most
of this debt and um
and so I felt so
um I didn't feel like I could offer much
because I I'm hopeless yeah I felt
hopeless because I I couldn't we
couldn't leave our son and so
um so I would be taking the kids to
school and I would it would be trash day
and I would see people's trash on the
side of the road and I said nice trash
um I can pick that up and we started
doing that and we had multiple yard
sales we would fill the garage up and we
would pull it all out and we wow we sold
other people's trash one man's trash
another man's treasure so that was
really that was really not major that's
your best side gig no that probably
wasn't the best probably my best side
gig is um I do care giving on the side I
love that's that I love taking care of
the elderly um I don't go into the
nursing homes I just take care of them
in their home so that's probably the
best and then the other one is probably
um I also iron for people on the side I
love it interesting so you're you
literally go pick up their house your
their clothes from their house take them
to your house iron them and redeliver
them yes wow
that's that's a service I might that's
uh it's really very very app yeah yeah a
lot of people it's like cooking they
don't know how to do it anymore you know
because we have these things called
restaurants that run into the kitchen
yeah well it just goes to show this is
where we open a box where there's a will
there's a way all right way I mean
picking up trash ironing people's
clothes
okay 80 000 in five years what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is congratulations thank you
um I think that it's when you live
according to God's design and you don't
try to make life work apart from God I
mean because when you do you you just
get frustrated and God hey and God has a
design for everything and he has a
are you so he has a design for money you
know and if we just do it his way you
know He blesses amen you have to we
've always made tithing a priority
[Music]
um
tithe you have to you have to put God
first because when you do God blesses
you you talk about when you know that
when you're responsible with your money
God looks down and God sees that you're
being and He blesses you and we have
yeah we're stewards of what he gives us
and we ought to be a good Steward and
then he just blesses that you know then
we're blessable you know and when you're
not blessable you know you know you make
life worth your way you know it it
doesn't work you go into debt amen amen
well done well done well certainly the
uh the videos you watched are all
biblically based as you know and so uh
yeah stuff like get out of debt the
borrowers leave the lender there's a
principle right there you know which you
guys did so fabulously now we did see a
video of you on YouTube about like 30
like year years ago where when when like
you had hair so you know yeah that one's
been that one's been going around
it's not real here more of a little comb
over actually but uh it was the last
vestiges before it gave up the ghost
that's uh I was like 30 something years
old yeah 32 years old or something yeah
it's crazy it is 30 years old that video
yeah wow yeah when we first started
doing this stuff all right guys way to
go hey we got a cop we got the live and
give box for you baby steps
Millionaire's book that's your next stop
and uh Total Money Makeover book as well
as the Financial Peace University
membership live them or give them all of
that way to go very proud of y'all thank
you congratulations all right Tim and
Karen from Detroit Michigan 80 000 paid
off in five years with their income get
this going from 36 to 80. don't tell me
it can't be done no whining making 136
after this call jump in count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one word debt free yeah
yeah baby yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is your one
place to find Reliable HVAC plumbing and
electrical providers near you Brands
like air serve Mr Rooter and Mr Electric
have local professionals ready to help
so stop wasting time scrolling through
the pages of results visit
neighborly.com today they're great folks
all right today's question comes from
Terry in Maryland my husband and I have
a HELOC with an adjustable rate it
started at 3.5 last year and now it's at
8.5 percent we owe 57 000 and our
current monthly payment is approximately
750 dollars we began paying an extra 500
toward it a month however this impacts
our lifestyle an ability to do the
things that we love such as travel
frequently as well as other Home
Improvements total owed with HELOC and
mortgage is about 429 000 are household
income is 275 000.
our only other debt is about payment
that we also make extra monthly payments
on
I'm trying to do my best here Dave is it
best to continue paying extra on the
current HELOC and hope the rates drop or
a find a loan with a lower fixed rate uh
fixed interest rate which may end up
being higher than the adjustable rate in
the future our goal is to pay this off
ASAP yet the eight percent makes this
difficult by the way my credit score is
800 plus
this is not be gentle this is not a long
time listener no this is not a long time
long time listeners don't close with
their credit score that's a good point
unless it's zero
Dave thank you Dave because you you gave
you gave Grace and now I shall I was
making fun of them all the way through
the whole email but there you go
Grace okay
you are a first time listener or a an
early listener to us
um
you've gotten yourself in a mess
the good news is you've got a great
great great great income to get yourself
out of this mess
um I probably would not move the HELOC
for now
um I'd keep it right where it's at what
I would do if I were you
um is I would start working our plan
you're you've obviously found us you
trust us enough to write us a letter
right so I'd start working through this
um I live I I want to know more about
them Dave but I try to bust that income
down to living on about a hundred
thousand a year and I'd be taking the
majority of it 175 000 a year paying off
this debt and I'd probably be trying to
be debt free house and all one year
pay off the HELOC of fifty seven
thousand pay off the boat we don't know
how much the boat is but pay them both
off in one year for God's sakes you make
275 000 freaking dollars a year yeah
your mortgage could be gone in two and a
half years hey they might not be able to
listen I'm listen you one of the things
I had to do
was
in order to get out in order to stop
being broke
was I had to stop the whining
that's so real I can so whine to myself
about how I work so hard I'm entitled I
and my wife would look at me and say
show this everyone
[Music]
call the wambulance I love Sharon
Sharon oh she's tough she's great she's
mean
she's hateful and stuff like that she's
crazy just bust your bubble man
so I had to learn to talk to myself
Terry so I'm gonna talk to you that way
call the wambulance about your little
travel plans yeah you have a freaking
boat you didn't even pay for there's
your travel plan so go out on the boat
since you already have it that's your
travel plan that's it you can't do
anything else you're not allowed to
leave because you have to pay off your
debt in one year 57 000 plus the debt
minus 275 is still a lot of freaking
money no whining Allowed no whining
we're trying to figure out a way to
interest rate trick yourself into
spending more than you make Congress has
tried it for years and it just doesn't
work
let's talk about the credit score
okay
why not why not because I to close with
that oh and by the way my credit score
is 800 plus all that indicates to me all
that indicates mathematically is that
they possibly plan on using that credit
score more in the future oh if you're
touting that that lets me know okay this
matters to you you want it to be right
so that possibly in the future you can
use it again there's only one way to get
an 800 credit score only one way what's
that Dave borrow a lot of money and pay
a lot of interest when you pay it all
back on time
and that's the only way this this means
you have been playing make out with the
bank in the back seat of the car that's
what the credit score means okay it
means you've been playing kissy face
with the bank that's all it means it
does not mean you have a net worth it
does not mean you have an income it
doesn't mean you have nothing but you've
been kissing the bank all the time and
the bank is a butterface
you know what that is no I can't talk
about this on the beach good just keep
it there it means everything looks good
but their face oh I got you I got you so
now I understand the bank is hiding the
true yeah yeah
they all look good at closing time okay
um so there we go yeah oh my gosh oh my
gosh here we go
just add that to your yeah it's getting
worse I gotta clean this up wait there's
a family too all right so
so here's the thing the point the credit
score is 100 derived by your interaction
with debt so bragging about your credit
scores like I love debt I love debt I
love debt that's why Jade is saying she
thinks you're going to go back in
dedicate here so if you want to do the
stuff we teach which is designed to get
you into wealth and peace as fast as
possible the shortest right way then
what you'd have to do is
uh get yourself out of debt and limit
your lifestyle to do that and so this is
about growing up
it's about adulting children do what
feels good adults devise a plan and
follow it so don't be playing kissy face
with the bank anymore you're not going
to borrow your way out of this you're
going to pay your way out of it thank
God you have a fabulous household income
and you don't have a lot of debt but you
do have a lot of symptoms of somebody
who's getting ready to make a huge mess
that's right I mean we just heard a
debt-free scream making thirty six
thousand they paid off 80 000 making
thirty six thousand yeah and it took
five years of sacrifice you've got maybe
12 months maybe yeah we don't know how
big the boat is you know that's still
that's true we don't know how big a boat
is or at least here we go there we go
that's it
the
that segment will go down in information
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jessica is in
Georgia Jessica how can we help right
quick
hi yes thank you so much for taking my
call um
long time listener actually ever since I
was the kid we will listen to you on the
radio oh thank you and
um yeah yeah so we really love parents
would even be like okay after that
episode what did you learn so
um yeah
and I'm just excited that I actually
have something I really love your advice
on um we've been really just diligently
praying and trying to Steward our
finances well we have uh 300 000 in cash
in the bank and we are trying to decide
do we invest this money into the market
since the market is low yeah you
basically it should increase in the next
two years or should we buy a house in
cash now you've been listening to the
show since you were a little bitty baby
girl
I actually have some very early memories
you completely know the answer to this
question
I know like you completely know the
answer choices like do I buy a house in
cash you know the answer option you know
the answer any different what's the
answer Jessica
[Music]
ding ding ding ding you get the prize
is it painful does it feel you know what
happened is you got some idiot friends
that haven't got 300 000 but they do
have an opinion
don't take Financial advice from your
broke friends yes we have don't take
Financial advice from your broke friends
and don't take Financial advice from
Tick Tock unless it's one of our in one
of our accounts but other than that you
should yes
yeah because it's all short-term
thinking it's all brought up by
adolescents yeah and so long-term
thinking pay cash for your house take
what would have been a house payment and
go get rich with it
exciting very quickly she's young to
have a paid for house I don't know where
they got the 300 Grand I don't either
God that's incredible beautiful
beautiful well done well done hey call
Terry in Maryland and tell her how to do
this this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships I'm Dave Ramsey
your host Jay boshaw Ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Helen is in Atlanta hi
Helen welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi um
if I'm calling um I forgot your name I'm
sorry but that's all right it's okay but
I have I have a question that I'm sure
you are here a lot it's a student loan
question I know you gotta like oh I'm so
sick of student loans
we know you're sick of them so we're
here to help you what's up
so I I'm kind of like in a very deep
hole I'm at the point where I'm very
hopeless at this point I'm trying to
figure out how can I handle my student
loan debt which is now at three hundred
and eleven thousand dollars which keeps
um growing as each day goes by my
interest rate on that student loan which
is 311 000 is um some of them are seven
percent some are 6.80 and some are 7.60
are they proud of all of them are they
private or public they're not private
they're they're public all of them with
the Department of Education okay
um what's your degree in I am
so I have three degrees I have one in um
Information Technology one in um
confluent management which that was
always the money
um and um I had a law degree
and so what do you make
um so right now I'm only making 85k
doing what
um right now I'm doing compliance
okay
why
um uh because well I was a staff
attorney
um but I wasn't making a lot of money as
a fast learning because I worked for a
non-profit
um I wanted to switch over
um to do more corporate
um type of legal work
um and that's when I switched over last
year
um to to this to try to try something
else
um and which I did get a pay bump in
making this transfer
um I am married I have a child
um
he only makes 50. okay how old is your
information technology degree
I was years old so you're not up you're
not up to Snuff on what's going on right
now then not at all not at all so your
best path to an income is through your
law degree
exactly okay can I ask about the your
spouse he makes 50K
you're not combining your income
um no we are not because well
why not we're not really combining our
income because he says my student loan
is my student loan so he's not
contributing to that does he have debt
um he he owes about he has a
there was a garnishment or whatever it's
not garnishing but
um he has a debt about 30 well more than
that he has a thirty thousand dollar
um debt plus he has a car loan I do not
have a car loan the only bet I have is
the house hmm so the house is in your
name
we we got troubles girlfriend
we have a lot of troubles in the house
basically if you add the house and you
add the student loan that I'm at half a
million dollars in debt at this point
yeah that's
um so number one chance you've the only
chance you've got to cleaning up his
mess and cleaning up your messes for you
guys to join forces and quit acting like
your roommates fighting over whose
mayonnaise it is in the dead gum
refrigerator
besides that boy child is no money
genius we've proven that already
so it's not like he's sitting over here
on some high horse
he's already behind he's further in debt
ratio to his income than you are and his
income potential so anyway number one uh
we need an attitude adjustment in our
marriage and learn to get on the same
page and work towards things together
um and then number two we're gonna have
to do something with your law degree
that makes you as much money as possible
and it's not what you're doing now
I mean a law degree you ought to be
north of six figures what was coming out
of the gate what was the intent when you
got that degree what was the intention
she's collecting degrees like a
thermometer
um my intent was always wanted to be an
attorney
um but but in the except for the part
when you did Conflict Management on the
part when you did it um yeah Information
Systems yeah I mean what's the next step
taking the bar you got the bar sure I've
already taken the bar yeah so staff
attorney so then what I I need to
understand what's stopping you from
making double what you're doing yeah
because the industry is not paying well
I'm not gonna I don't want to litigate
um that's one thing I do not want to
wear the game why
um so after because I I've done it for
three years and I hated it
in the first 30 years
I did it for three years oh three three
years okay
and I hated it and I was like in
depression the only the only option that
I saw out of this situation is to work
for a non-profit which you know that's
not gonna make that much money at all it
doesn't work you need to make some money
in 10 years yeah you guys both need to
make as much money as you can possibly
make because you have a deep deep hole
and a medium-sized to small shovel and
we need to get the size of your shovel
up your income up and some of the jobs
that you do here here you can make a
hundred thousand dollars more a year you
could be out of this debt in three years
yeah even if you didn't like what you
were doing like litigation for three
whole years if you made if you made 185
we'll go do it for three years and shut
up exactly because it's less depressing
dealing with litigation than it is
dealing with three hundred and eleven
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and that's the mic drop
yeah I'm still here yeah I'm still here
I'm not sure it's litigation I don't
care but you're hiding in these stupid
but half paying corporate jobs while you
need to go at the tip of the spear and
go make some dead gun money for the good
of your life because you're looking at a
mountain don't know how I'm gonna climb
it and you're standing there with a law
degree in your hand
so you it's an income issue you can make
it out at 85 but it's going to take you
three or four times longer you can make
it out without your husband's
participation but it's going to take you
three or four times longer and oh by the
way when you do finally get out dumb
butt's gonna still be in debt over there
yeah what we're telling you the the you
part of it is just such a small part of
this equation because if you're getting
up your income think about think about
this if you double your income he
doubles his income you guys attack this
thing together you're moving quickly and
you're on the same page and you're gonna
be wealthy
you'd be wealthy or end up wealthy at
the end of the story
he can't double his income because he
doesn't have any of the education behind
us as well as he's not motivated
second part not the first part the
problem is he's not motivated because I
don't care if he doubles his income in
his field I just want him to go out
working and bringing in more income I
don't care if he's delivering pizzas I
want him to get after this because you
guys together decide that this is what
you need to do it's emotionally
debilitating to be doing it by yourself
when you're married
so it's very hard but you guys it is an
income to debt ratio problem
mathematically get your income up so
that you can attack this faster and
faster and faster and faster and look at
it as a temporary thing it doesn't have
to be a career choice it's a temporary
thing you need to do something and go
make an extra 100K a year
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
she shall forever be known as everyone
else
Dave and everyone and everyone else it's
like a band it's like my co-host
everyone else
that's good we got a lot of input that
way that's right
lots of input Lots
it's in Orlando hey Joshua welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave well
a lot of big life changes have happened
to me recently uh last December I
graduated with my aerospace engineering
degree wow I recently got an entry-level
engineering position at Nasa uh making
70 000 a year he is a rocket scientist
okay
I also just got married last week and my
wife makes 40 000 a year and we are
about to finish baby step two we've been
doing it for about four months and crazy
enough we have paid off forty thousand
dollars in debt by selling my fancy
truck and everything else way to go
um my question is my wife and I have
always had this dream of owning like 15
20 acres of land uh having cattle goats
chickens having a bunch of kids
um and if you were in my shoes
how would you go about doing this we
would love to build a house but we know
in the past you said that's not really
optimal
um for first-time homebuyers uh we were
even thinking about just buying the land
you know putting RV on the land for a
year or two and then slowly building a
house just what are your thoughts and
all this and how would you go about
doing this
okay
um so you got married when
last week
so we always have wanted you out for a
week
um please tell me you're not on your
honeymoon right now okay
Congratulations by the way a lot of
wonderful things so you're what 23-24
uh 27 I was in uh school for eight years
um changed major once and then I had to
drop out dude how old is she
he is 26. okay all right
um
we have done a lot of sacrificial things
in our lives I've been married 41 years
to hit our goals uh never once was one
of them my wife considered that she
would live in an RV for one of my goals
that never that was never one of the
possibilities
um like not a freaking chance okay I'm
just saying so we rent an apartment
first or something I don't know so uh I
could be wrong but that might you guys
really want a piece of land and I think
that's wonderful I like dirt too I've
got some dirt myself and
um uh but uh
yeah the living and the RV thing unless
she's uh an unusual lady that's probably
not her dream that might be your well
it's actually her idea believe it or not
and I'm all for it but uh an unusual
well I just yeah I don't believe but
okay I mean I didn't believe it till you
said it so I believe I believe what you
say but all right um it's uh
what would I do I don't know what you'll
do because you're willing to do things
I'm not willing to do and my wife is not
willing to do namely living in an RV
okay and so uh at any stage of our life
no matter how sacrificial we've been or
how broke we've been that never was on
the list so uh uh I mean we've lived in
some dumpy one bedroom apartments to get
there but never to do that not saying
one's better than the other I'm just
saying not something that Sharon's going
to say anyway all that to say we would
buy a nice starter home that is very
generic because generic homes Is Not
Unusual in other words they go up in
value more likely than weird homes and
then we would get that thing and we pay
it down as fast as we could pay it down
somewhere along in there we'd save up
some money and pay cash for the land uh
we'd sell the house and we'd rent while
we built on the land and that would be
the two-step procedure that we would do
and it's we did that but we did it over
a number of years uh I wouldn't think
it's going to take you guys that long
but I mean your first place
it just feels uh like bad relational
advice for me to tell you as Dave Ramsey
that your first home after you've been
married a week should be an RV well
there's there's a fairy tale
element to this it's like we just got
married this is our Dream to have this
land in this house with lots of kids and
um I would live under a bridge for you
yeah until I'm under the bridge
if you go somewhere you get a small
starter house first or you know whatever
that is at least it has the ability to
appreciate some value over time while
you're saving we know that RV is not
going to do that that's a good point you
know so there's that piece of it and
then
either way there's going to be some time
that you're going to wait here because
you've got to buy the land so you may as
well wait
in a house in a home yeah yeah so I I
would just buy something very boring
kinda yeah maybe that's your first home
and concentrate on uh your first year of
marriage so there's a scripture in the
Old Testament that talks about in first
Samuel that the Warriors
in the in Israel in the time of Samuel
uh we're not allowed to go to war their
first year of marriage they were
required to invest in their marriage for
the first year so um and at times I
built several homes with my wife over
the years and at times it's it's some
similar to War
I see where you're going with this now I
get it no I mean the last the last
couple have been pretty good yeah uh the
first one we about killed each other but
the uh um yeah and The Decorator almost
had The Decorator assessment but I found
out that was illegal so um you can't do
that Dave but the um
yeah so that's you it's
really getting to know each other and
spending your energy on
the project of relationship building
instead of the project of Home Building
that's so true that's that's just good
uh first year of marriage try to try to
take on as few complicated and large
projects as possible I agree in the
first year
um there's enough to deal with just your
mother-in-law I mean there's just that
and so you are correct her mother-in-law
or I don't know your mother I don't I
mean whatever you know I don't know it's
something it could be a mother it could
be a father you could have an
overbearing controlling father like my
kids and so you know that that could
happen but yeah I mean you got to learn
to deal with it and I you can do all of
that Joshua but you're a you're you're a
very precise-minded individual and
um
I suspect uh the project of building a
home will be very precise for you oh
yeah and uh so I really want you to
precisely and I if you're a muscle and I
would tell you to not do anything for
you yeah just like you heard me say
before and if you did do something it'd
be a boring little starter house and
then let's make the building on the land
the step two second home second home and
it's gonna it's still gonna be fun yeah
the whole process is going to be fun
you've got time you guys are yeah it's
gonna be fun and you know word of the
wise goats aren't as fun as they sound
like they are open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and you're running now I will get hate
mail from the goat people but um there
we go I hadn't offended as many people
today so I thought I'd just add to the
list all right that's the process
so it's a good thing
like I talked to a couple uh I remember
gosh many years ago on the show and it
was first time I ran into this they
were worth about two million dollars and
they did what he's talking about I was
kind of in all of them and that what
they did they bought a a five thousand
dollar single wide extremely used
trailer
and stuck it on a piece of land and
lived there until they saved up three
hundred thousand dollars cash and then
they built a cash house and and fast
forward were sitting with them they're
not even 30 and they're worth over a
million dollars with a paid for 300 000
house on a nice track of land and we're
down in the Alabama area at the time and
that was the first time I'd heard
somebody going that extreme and they're
like you're gonna love this and I'm like
yeah
I love that you did it yeah and uh but
I'm no Sharon was not gonna do that that
was not on her list and I don't it's not
wrong there is a level of sacrifice that
you're going to endure the depth of it
will the deeper the faster you're
propelled but the depth of it is your
choice yeah yeah that's good and the
fact that they did a thousand dollar
Arby that was a single wide yeah
worse this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage George
and Carol are with us hey guys how are
you funny you Dave you're doing great
better than we deserve same here same
here welcome where do you live San
Antonio Texas all right fun how much
data have you paid off paid off six
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
how long did that take it took us 39
months 30. yeah I've got to do this a
lot that's a lot and your range of
income during that uh three years and
three months we started out at uh 313
000 and ended at 348 000. goodness
gracious what do you all do for a living
I'm a retired Soldier 30 years army
retired medically retired and uh 25
years retired Air Force wow and that's
the this is all retirement income
no and also well I retired in um 2010
and they picked me up as doing the same
thing I really I get individuals
deployed ah that is much uh Civil
Service oh okay all right so all of that
combined wow yes sir well thank you for
your service both of your career then
wow and San Antonio definitely that
makes sense okay very cool whoa so 620
000 uh that's your house yes sir oh look
at that weird people you are debt free
baby yeah I love it what's this house
worth
a million dollars now wow come on
somebody
I love it and you got this fabulous
military retirement thank you thank you
thank you for your service over and over
and over again and uh
uh you got other Nest Egg built yes sir
how much so we have over seven hundred
thousand dollars in retirement we have
um so you're worth around two million
dollars yes sir
wow wow wow wow because of you uh
because of you any of it
you have to tighten the shot group man
that's something yeah put those rounds
down range over in the right direction I
like it I have to be transparent with
you Dave because at first I did not want
to do it I was totally yeah but she
might tighten the shot group so you need
to be careful
this is not a lady you want to mess with
I can tell
so how did she get you to do it other
than threatening you with a shot group
well believe it or not uh I have to give
it to uh two couples uh a jazz and Chris
Brown and Leonard and Pam Turner
Jazz and Chris Brown they came to our
house and taught us FPU for nine weeks
wow one-on-one because I was totally
against it whoa and force fed you yes
and once we got a board I was Hook Line
and Sinker okay so how many weeks into
you being force-fed did it turn into you
were the you were gang on game on I say
on the third week okay and I had to cut
those credit cards okay all right all
right I mean what kind of friend does
that that's a friend that sure is we
were in the same life group we had a IRS
debt we were married eight years ago
today's our anniversary
when we were married we didn't join our
income
so we were just living paycheck to
paycheck when the bills came in we paid
them he paid his bills I paid my bills
but 39 months ago we had well it was
four years ago we had an IRS that over
eleven thousand dollars and so I said
Hey Baby Slow Down on the spending
because we owed IRS eleven thousand
dollars
and about a week after that I was at
home in a
palette of mulch was dropped off at the
house and I called him up and asked him
how much it was they paid over 700 for
this Mulch and we still owe the IRS and
I lost my mind
that and that was my I've had it yes it
was and here comes the force feeding
him I was volunteering at the homeless
shelter and every story was the same
with the women
um husband died or husband used up the
entire nest egg and you look up and now
she's homeless and that wasn't going to
be me I said in my family I started with
my grandmother she died with that I said
my mother who's a widow who's in dire
need of money without an ass stake I did
not want that to be me yeah you still
love it that it says I saw all of that
in the mulch
so to speak yeah whoa that yeah that
pile of manure will get your attention
it sure will oh that's fun now I
remember you guys I met you guys on a
coordinator rally right yes so
did that transformation happen to where
someone's Force feeding you FPU now
you're doing it and now you're doing it
um we had a again Chris and Brad Jasmine
Brown they were teaching the course in
our church so my wife was like hey we
want to do that as well so we joined
them um did a coal host guest with them
and after that we're like hey we need to
do one of our own I love it wow what
church you go to now word Covenant
Church in San Antonio Texas well thanks
for teaching it we appreciate it very
very much our church is also debt-free
in this I love it I love it you guys are
a force to be reckoned with uh what do
you tell people now that you're
coordinating you pay off 620 000 in
three years and some change oh my gosh
house and everything worth two million
dollars retired military you're living
the American dream tell them how to
become debt free what'd you do for that
three years we joined forces
we got on a budget
and we tightened up our shot
everything else was secondary to that we
stayed the cell intensity through the
whole thing we did not give up and um so
what we do now is if I see someone like
say a plumber or electrician come to the
house I say hey uh how's your finances
they'll talk to us a little bit then
I'll go and I'll grab one of your books
and I'll pass it to them say hey
um you might want to read this wow so
we're trying to give it back yeah
something the Lord didn't give us all
these resources to expend it all that's
right because we give that glory to God
because if it wasn't for him we would
not be standing here at this time no
that's true that's true for sure well
done you guys you're amazing Your Heroes
in so many ways beautifully beautifully
done how's it feel to have no payments
in the world
outstanding free peace
we're not in flight or fight mode
anymore yes yeah no homeless shelter
because of uh a pallet of the BS
we're in a position to help others the
widows the orphans the single parents to
the homeless clove feed we're allowed to
focus on our Ministries amen amen you
guys are beautiful you're fabulous I
love it I love it I love it well we've
got the live and give box for you it
sounds like you've got good use for it
the baby steps millionaires book which
you're living proof that that happens
you are baby steps Millionaires and The
Total Money Makeover book as well and
then another Financial Peace University
membership you'll find a good use for
that I'm sure for someone coming into
one of your classes that that maybe that
helps them get started so very well done
you guys are amazing George and Carol
San Antonio Texas wow 620 000 paid off
house and everything Landing them in a 2
million dollar net worth making 30 did
that in 39 months making 313 to 348
military retirement plus continuing to
work count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
oh
love it
wow
I love it
goals yeah hashtag goals all the years
of doing this I have never heard Titan
the shot group in reference to that I've
heard it when I'm on the shooting range
but I've never heard it in reference to
that looks Carol Carol is not messing
around
she does not miss I wouldn't want to be
downrange
what a great Target what a great job
Heroes man very quick
you know you're out there right now
you're 19 or you're 20 years old uh
you're starting your military career did
you listen to that young man real woman
did you listen to that unbelievable
that's where those people are and they
did that serving their country so
beautiful beautiful very well done wow
ding ding ding ding ding this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Ecclesiastes 10
10 if the ax is dull and its Edge
unsharpened more strength is needed but
skill will bring success
Henry Ford said most people spend more
time and energy going around the
problems than trying to solve them Dr
Stephen Covey in his book Seven Habits
used to talk about are the
tree beater
that if you sit you know uh one
Lumberjack goes in with an ax and he's
knocking down I don't know make it up 20
trees a day and the next day 23s a day
the next day 23s a day the other guy
comes in he's doing 20 25 trees a day
then he's doing 15 trees a day then 10
trees a day finally goes over the guy
who's constant consistently doing it he
said what are you doing he said well
every morning I have to sharpen my ax
and you keep a sharp ax the trees go
down yeah and you keep sharp if the ax
is dull and it's Edge unsharpened more
strength is needed but skill will bring
success Ecclesiastes says there you go
good word must have been where he got
that open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Annie is with
us in San Francisco hi Annie how are you
hi I'm great it's so nice to talk to you
you too what's up
um all of a sudden I got very nervous so
it's okay we've never lost a patient how
can we help good good to hear it well
I'm trying to figure out if we should
keep our earthquake insurance and I
would love your advice yes I live in San
Francisco
okay well we are so we are not in San
Francisco we are in a suburb of San
Francisco specifically okay I mean
you're in an earthquake zone
we are but it's what I cannot figure out
is why we are we seem to be the only
Chumps in our 1.8 million dollar house
because all the houses here are insanely
priced we seem to be the only ones who
have kept our earthquake insurance I
have talked to so many of my neighbors
and our friends in this town nobody else
seems to have purchased it or kept it
once our our premiums went way up well
if they went high enough I don't know
what they are I guess I should have
asked that
um I don't know what the how high they
are but I mean there are people that buy
earthquake insurance in Tennessee that's
humorous yeah yeah because there's not
been an earthquake in Tennessee because
it's probably but it's probably super
cheap ours for the longest time ours was
about 2 000 a year and in the last
couple of years our premium has gone up
to 6 000 a year so it's more expensive
than our home I mean by far so what
would I mean again all insurance is
probabilities
it's all statistics
that establishes price okay right and so
what they're trying to determine like
for instance it's it's very difficult to
get homeowners insurance of any kind in
Florida now
because of hurricanes right because the
insurance companies have abandoned the
state because of that
um one of the problems you guys are
facing in California is a lot of the
insurance companies have abandoned the
state because your state government are
idiots
and the regulations are crazy and so uh
they've driven businesses out that that
they don't want they don't want to write
in California because it's just too
difficult with the regulations so I that
may be what's driving this up it could
be but it could be just statistics that
okay if we're more if we're an insurance
company we're going to cover a thousand
million dollar houses million eight
hundred thousand dollar houses would you
say yours was then um and on average out
of a thousand of them how much are going
to have earthquake damage in a 10-year
period of time
you know then okay that's 60 000 bucks
and so that you know they're running the
statistics down uh or 600 000 bucks they
run the stats down on actually that they
actually make money on all insurance if
they do their statistics right all
Insurance makes money but some of it's
work not worth some of it's not worth
the risk on our part so we take it right
but so what's your household income
our household income it depends on the
year but it's between 350 and 450 000.
okay and so if if the house
uh I mean what you got to think about is
just the probability uh what is the
chances of a total Destruction of this
house while you live there I mean there
have been severe earthquakes in the last
100 years in San Francisco right 200
years for sure absolutely right and
it'll happen again for sure I
for that reason actually all of the
insurers don't actually ensure for
earthquake in California right we all
have to get it if we want it through the
California earthquake Authority which is
like a public you know it's like a
private and that's the six thousand
dollars
yeah exactly so like our State Farm Home
Insurance
yeah exactly exactly yeah because they
couldn't figure out they couldn't figure
out the probabilities on it I I have a
right I have a question
in my mind and I could be totally wrong
in my mind I'm thinking okay 1.8 million
dollars this is gonna cost me
500 bucks a month
I feel like I would just do it for the
probability of living where there's such
a pro some some sort of damage even if
it's not catastrophic right with your
income and I know the ratios are
different in San Francisco but I'm
thinking with your income how big of a
piece how big a piece of 500 of your
world is 500 a month it's not because it
makes
because all of these other people who
have incomes you know either around ours
or north of ours you know they don't
seem to have it but if there's an
earthquake they're going to be the chump
but yeah I mean but it's a matter it's
just a matter of probabilities what do
you change I mean in in the how long are
you going to live in this house you know
I'm gonna live there 10 years what's the
chances of a total loss in that 10-year
period of time no one knows obviously
but that's how you would decide if
you're a trump and so it doesn't make
you a chump it's uh to buy it or for
that matter not to buy it they have
chosen
the other people to become self-insured
they're taking the risk themselves
obviously you're already aware of that
and so like I've got a friend that has a
house
um on the beach in Mexico okay the the
area that he's in has small uh tropical
storms and occasional small hurricanes
the house is almost totally concrete
because it's built for that area and so
if a hurricane comes through there it's
going to like blast his furniture blast
the windows out but the rest of the
house will be just fine and uh he
probably saw hurricane insurance down
there and it was ridiculous I mean it
was like 25 000 a year and he's like nah
I'll just self-insure it
and he's got plenty of money he can re
if the whole stinking thing blows down
he can build it back yeah right but he's
just like I'm I'm just gonna you know
I'm gonna put hurricane shutters on it
I'm gonna take care of the house and you
know he was describing It All To Me it
made sense it made sense that he's
taking the risk but he can take the risk
so if you if the house fell down do you
have a mortgage on it
we have about 375
000 left on it what's your net worth I
was just about to ask
um depending on which way the wind blows
were between 5.3 and 5.7 so this is not
it doesn't ruin your life
this is just a peace argument is it
giving you peace or is it not giving you
peace it will having it make you sleep
better at night well not having it make
it make you sleep better at night
oh that's a good question Jade it gives
me peace okay and you're not a challenge
it also makes me feel like I'm a trump
I will mathematically tell you you're
not a chump you freaking live in San
Francisco earthquakes occur okay you're
not a chump you're not you're not
getting messed over if you told me 60
000 a year I'd be going there getting
messed over but six thousand no you're
not uh it did go way up but the reason
way up is the more the uh insurance
companies got hammered by California
claims on earthquake that's why they
quit writing it and then the only way to
get it is get it through a socialized
thing with the state a public private
right socialism and so yeah that's the
only way you can get it and that's part
of what that's the only way you can get
dead gum insurance in Florida right now
just about there's just a few companies
riding it very difficult and so
um it's the exact same thing it's the
probability the event becomes hard to
predict so the insurance companies
aren't going to cover it yeah so I don't
I mean I know a lot about Actuarial
tables and I don't think you're a chump
but I don't think you'd be a chump if
you're self-insured it either it's not a
you're not you're not measurably dumb
either way it's just no fun writing a
500 check every month to something that
is very fluid that puts this hour of the
rims you're showing the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started